luis receives a gift card worth $25 to
an online retailer that sells digital
music and games each song costs $0.99 or
89 cents and each game costs a dollar 99
he wants to buy at least he wants to buy
at least 15 items with this card set up
a system of inequalities that represents
this scenario and identify the range of
possible purchases using a graph and
that's why we have some graph paper over
here so let's define some variables
let's let s equal the number of songs he
buys number of songs and then let's let
G equal the number of games that he buys
now if we look at this constraint right
here he wants to buy at least 15 items
with this card so the total number of
items are going to be the number of
songs plus the number of games and that
has to be at least 15 so it has to be
greater than or equal to 15 so that's
what that constraint tells us right
there and then the other constraint is
the gift card is worth $25 so the amount
that he spends on songs plus the amount
that he spends on games has to be less
than or equal to 25 so the amount that
he spends on songs are going to be the
number of songs he buys the number of
songs he buys times the cost per song
times 89 cents times I'll say zero point
eight nine times s that's how much he
spends on songs plus the cost per game
which is a dollar ninety nine times the
number of games this is going to be the
total amount that he spends and that has
to be less than or equal to twenty five
less than or equal to 25 now if we want
to graph these we first kind of have to
define the axes so let me do that right
here and we only care about the first
quadrant because we only care about
positive values for the number of songs
in the number of games we don't talk
about scenarios where he buys a negative
number of songs or games so we're just
going to be just the positive quadrant
right here let me draw the axes so let's
make this let's make the vertical axis
that I'm drawing right here
let's make that the vertical axis and
and let's call that the song axis so
that's the number of songs he buys let
me make sure you can see that that is
the song axis and then let's make this
this horizontal that's going to be the
number of games he buys just bowled it
in the number number of games he buys
number of games and just to make sure
just to make sure that we can fit on
this page because I'm a feeling we're
going to get to reasonably large numbers
let's make each of these boxes equal to
2 so this would be 4 8 12 16 20 so on
and so forth and this would be 4 this
obviously would be 0 4 8 4 8 12 16 20
and so on so let's see if we can graph
these two constraints well this first
constraint s + G is going to be greater
than or equal to 15 the easiest way to
think about this or the easiest way to
graph this is to really think about the
intercepts if G is 0 if G is 0 what is s
well s plus 0 has to be greater than or
equal to 15 so if G is 0 s is going to
be greater than or equal to 15 let me
put it this way so if I'm going to graph
this one right here if G is 0 s is
greater than or equal to 15 so G is 0 s
15 is reciept this is 12 14 15 is right
over there and s is going to be all of
the values equivalent to that or greater
than for G equal to 0 if s is equal to 0
G is greater than or equal to 15 so if s
is equal to 0 G is greater than or equal
to 15 so G is greater than or equal to
15 so the boundary line s + G is equal
to 15 you would just have to connect
these two dots let me try my best to
connect these dots so it would look
something like this this is always the
hardest part
see how well I can connect these two
dots nope can you see actually get a
line tool for this so that's pretty good
so that's the line s plus G is equal to
50 and we talked about the values
greater than 15 we're going to go above
the line and you saw that when G is
equal to 0 s is greater than or equal to
15
it's all of these values up here and
when G when s was 0 G was greater than
or equal to 15 so this constraint right
here is all of this all of this area
satisfies this all of this area if you
pick any coordinate here it represents
and really you should think about the
integer coordinates because we're not
going to buy parts of games but if you
think about all of the integer
coordinates here they represent
combinations of s and G where you're
buying at least 15 games for example
here you're buying 8 games and 16 songs
that's 24 so you're definitely meeting
the first constraint now the second
constraint 0.89 s plus 199 G is less
than or equal to 25 this is a starting
point let's just draw the line let's
draw the line 0.89 s plus 199 is equal
to 25 and then we could think about what
the less than what what region the less
than would represent 199 G and the
easiest way to do this once again we
could do slope y-intercept of all that
type of thing but the easiest way to
just find the s and the G intercepts so
if s is equal to 0 if s is equal to 0
then we have 199 G is equal to 25 so s
is equal to 0 then we have 199 G is
equal to 25 or G is equal to its going
to calculator out for this so if we take
25 divided by 199 it is twelve point
five six G is equal to twelve point five
six let me get it twelve point five six
and then if so when s is 0 let me plot
this when s is 0 G is twelve point five
six this is 12 this is 14 twelve point
five six is going to be right right
there a little bit
more than 12 that's that value there and
then let's do the same thing if G is 0
so if G is equal to 0 then we have so
this term goes away we have zero point 8
9 s if we use just the equality here the
equation is equal to 25 or s is equal to
calculator out again so if we take 25
divided by 0.8 9 we get it's equal to 28
point zero eight just a little over
twenty eight so twenty-eight point zero
eight so that is G is 0 s is 28 so that
is two for twenty four six eight little
over 28 so it's right over there
so this line 0.89 s plus 199 G is equal
to 25 is going to be it's going to go
from this coordinate which is 0 28 so
that point right there all the way down
to the point twelve point five six zero
so let me see if I can draw that I'm
going to go and draw one more attempt
maybe if I start from the bottom it'll
be easier that was a better attempt let
me Bowl that in a little bit so you can
make sure you can see it so that line
represents this right over here now if
we're talking about the the less than
area what will that imply so when if we
think about it when G is equal to zero
point eight nine s is less than 25 so
when G is equal to zero if we really
wanted the less than there we could
think of it this way it's less than
instead of just doing less than or equal
to so s is less than 28 point oh eight
so it'll be the region below it'll be
the region below when s is 0 G so if we
think s is zero if we use this original
equation $1.99 G will be less than or
equal to I use this just to plot the
graph but if we actually care about the
actual inequality we get $1.99 G is less
than 25 G would be less than or equal to
twelve point five six so when s is equal
to G
zero G is less than twelve point five
six so the area that satisfies this
second constraint is everything below
this graph everything below this graph
now we want the region that satisfies
both constraints so it's going to be the
overlap of the regions that satisfy one
of the two so the overlap is going to be
this region right here below the orange
graph and above the blue graph including
including both of them so if you pick
any combination so if he buys four if he
buys four four games and 14 songs that
would work or if we bought two games and
16 songs that would work so you can kind
of get the idea anything in that region
and you can only buy integer values
would satisfy both constraints